spoiler warning for avengers and game
give up thanos you're finished we're
tired of your memes
they're as good as dead i mean they're
on facebook now
fine if this universe can no longer
appreciate
thanos car memes and i'll start a brand
new one that
will no
were you expecting something to happen i
uh
i was kind of hoping i was worthy of
mjolnir and i could just kind of summon
it
hold on i'm getting a text
stop calling me i will not help you
fight i
thought i made that clear last thursday
awkward
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
we're not america's ass but we are the
ass of youtube so there's no denying
that avengers end game was full of a lot
of
instantly iconic scenes tony's snapped
ant-man taco sequence
fat thor but in a movie full of awesome
moments
none not one was as thrilling as
watching captain america using mjolnir
to fight
thanos just paint the scene since we
don't fully have access to the footage
yet thor is attacking thanos with
stormbreaker when the tables suddenly
turn
thanos is pressing the axe closer and
closer into chris hemsworth's chiseled
bod
or i guess beer bellied bod in this
movie when out of nowhere
thanos is knocked away by the hammer
pull back to see mr
america's ass wielding asgard's
mightiest weapon
and all the lightning powers that come
with it ah it is so good
even though we can't show it since the
home version isn't released yet just
talking about it with our little
animations here is still getting me
hyped for this scene but after getting
me hyped
it then got me curious who else could
wield mjolnir mjolnir is after all a
weapon that judges a person's worthiness
so who else in this enormous cast of
characters could make
the cut should hawkeye be trading in his
bow could black widow have finally found
herself a decent weapon other than
gun or maybe just maybe thanos could
have wielded the hammer for himself
by looking at steve and thor's actions
across these movies
and when they can or can't lift the
hammer we can start piecing together
where mjolnir's threshold of worthiness
lies
and from there judge whether anyone else
would pass the test
the best place to start when it comes to
defining worthiness is of course the
original thor from 2011. when the movie
begins
odin is bragging to thor and loki about
how he heroically defeated the frost
giants and then
pulls the greatest jerk move of all when
he reprimands thor for wanting to do the
same thing
a wise king never seeks out
war but he must always be ready for it a
wise king also apparently hides his
warmongering past behind centuries of
propaganda but don't worry
that won't become important for another
two movies at least flash forward a few
thousand years from that opening scene
and thor is about to be crowned king of
asgard
thor makes three vows during the
ceremony he swears to guard the nine
realms to preserve the peace
and finally to cast aside all selfish
ambitions for the good of the realm so
that already starts to outline the
criteria that we might end up working
with
during the coronation frost giants
attack thor throws himself a hissy fit
that his coronation was interrupted and
swears vengeance on the frost giants
you are a vain cruel boy
you are an old man and a fool thereby
breaking his oath to defend the nine
realms
odin doesn't take it all that well
realize what you've done what you've
started i was protecting my heart
[Music]
it's pretty obvious why thor would be
deemed unworthy here and he spends most
of the rest of the movie deep powered
back on earth it's
only after thor recognizes that violence
isn't always
the answer and he chooses to willingly
sacrifice his life for earth's safety
that mjolnir suddenly deems thor worthy
once again
the hammer flies to thor in his dying
moments and he's back into fighting
shape which is kind of an odd message
but okay it tells us
two major things here in the eyes of
odin
sorry in the eye of odin worthiness
requires you to
only use violence as a last resort and
it also requires you to be willing to
sacrifice your life for a greater good
the story of captain america
actually supports these two
qualifications as well no one can doubt
that steve's intentions are pure
throughout his movies he's
fighting in world war ii to stop a force
of evil and ultimately protect the
people and by the end of the first
avenger
he too has made the ultimate sacrifice
he gives up his life to protect
others this is why even as far back as
age of ultron
steve was deemed worthy by mjolnir look
back on the hammer lifting scene from
that movie it is one of the best moments
in the entirety of this franchise
not only is it hilarious but it's also a
pure distillation of each of these
various characters
tony is trying to outsmart mjolnir with
technology hawkeye is just kind of lost
in this world of magic and superheroes
banner plays off everything as a joke
the entire time
the hammer refuses to budge but when
steve tries to pick it up
we see it move ever so slightly but it
does
move back then i think most of us wrote
that scene off as captain america
almost being worthy to lift the hammer
but not quite being all the way there
however
looking back on the scene now that
endgame has happened the truth is clear
captain america could lift the hammer
the entire time he just played it off
like he couldn't in order to not stand
out above the others as director anthony
russo himself confirms quote in our
heads he was able to wield it
he didn't know that until that moment in
ultron when he tried to pick it up but
cap's sense of character and humility
and out of deference to thor's ego
cap in that moment realizing he can move
the hammer
decides not to end quote that's why an
end game thor calls out
thor like us suspected that something
else was going on but couldn't be 100
sure until it actually happened and in
hindsight it
actually puts an even more interesting
twist on this moment from the first
avenger
you don't give up do you you could have
the power of the gods
choosing not to pursue the power of the
tesseract in that first movie
is a big reason why steve is actually
able to access the power of the gods by
the time
ultron and end game roll around and this
is back in the first movie god i'm just
really blown away by little details like
this it's
really impressive anyway the moral here
is that power is granted to those who
don't
seek it out cap being worthy all the way
back in ultron may also explain another
key moment in the franchise
remember what odin says whoever holds
this hammer
if he be worthy shall possess the power
so really
cap from the moment he touches the
hammer is working with the power of thor
so maybe that's how a normal human like
steve rogers would be able to hold back
thanos's fully stoned gauntlet at the
end of infinity war it's just a thought
and yes i know that the co-writer of
that movie christopher marcus said it
was because
thanos was dumbfounded at the brazenness
of steve thinking he could hold back a
titan but that's kind of dumb it was
totally the power of odin that is my
personal canon now anyway this all
brings us to the main question of the
day
who else could pass mjolnir's test by
the end of endgame
surprisingly it's more than you might
think let's start off with the obvious
one
tony the tony stark who appears in
endgame is a
far cry from the tony stark who failed
to lift the hammer back in age of ultron
at the time he was arrogant and selfish
but his overconfidence is something that
he largely loses in the wake of ultron's
destruction of sokovia
just like thor's time on earth taught
him humility sokovia taught tony that
others were suffering because of his
actions and that he needed to be more
responsible but even at the end of that
movie he still wasn't worthy because he
was selfish
it wouldn't be until infinity war that
tony would actually overcome that other
barrier
him hopping aboard thanos's ship was him
giving up what he loved
pepper potts for the good of earth he
didn't anticipate coming home from that
trip
yeah he backslides a little bit at the
beginning of end game but by the time of
the snap he's back
very solidly into the worthy column
sacrificing a perfect life with his
family for the greater good which
honestly makes his sacrifice that much
more unfortunate since
as we saw at the end of thor the power
of mjolnir can actually bring those on
the brink of death
back to life so instead of that
prolonged tearful goodbye with peter and
pepper they should have just given him
the hammer and revived him but they
didn't and now he's dead
moving on natasha romanov aka black
widow
when she's first given the chance to try
lifting mjolnir during the ultron scene
she declines it
by claiming that's not a question i need
answered well maybe not you natasha but
we all do
now admittedly natasha has a spotty past
of assassination and murder
i got read in my lecture but when you
actually look at her behavior throughout
the mcu
she's done nothing but selfless acts her
entire life in an attempt to atone for
her mistakes and even those past
mistakes weren't
really her fault to begin with she was
kind of forced into them multiple times
as she herself says in endgame i used to
have nothing
and then i got this this job
this family i was better because of it
her commitment to self-sacrifice for a
greater good
is ingrained in her character in winter
soldier she exposes alexander pierce's
evil schemes
knowing that in the process she'll also
be exposing her own crimes which will
then force her back into hiding
she then signs the sokovia accords
because she believes that the heroes do
need to be more accountable but then she
goes on to help captain america
in his own personal quest to find
justice which causes her to again have
to adopt status as a fugitive
so basically in civil war she's giving
herself the worst of both worlds
all in pursuit of helping others even on
her
normal missions she's willing to lay
down her life five years ago i was
escorting a nuclear engineer out of iran
but the winter soldier was there
i was covering my engineer so he shot
him straight through me
as for the other half of worthiness
black widow doesn't actively choose to
fight
and even warns those who are more worthy
than herself
against entering battle you know what's
about to happen do you really want to
punch your way out of this one
and like i alluded to earlier she is a
weapon that was created by other people
she didn't choose this life this life
chose her and she's trying to make the
best of it and
all of this of course climaxes in her
moment of ultimate sacrifice for the
soul stone in
end game so would black widow be worthy
of holding mjolnir
yes a hundred percent yes she has more
than redeemed herself and would
absolutely be seen as worthy in the eyes
of hammer she was probably worthy as far
back as age of ultron
the brilliant part here though is that
she's not worthy based on her own
standards the choice to have her not
lift the hammer in ultron
showed that external signs of worthiness
don't matter to her
it's more about how she feels about her
own character which is
again sad since had she tried to pick up
the hammer and been successful she would
have seen that she's not as irredeemable
as she thought
i had this dream that kind of seems
normal at the time but when you wake
what is true but i was an avenger that i
was anything more than the assassin
they made me and that again is what
makes these movies so
awesome strong emotional theming adding
yet
another level of insult to injury is the
fact that if she hadn't sacrificed
herself for the soul stone
her plus mjolnir would have been a lot
more useful in that final battle against
thanos than hawkeye i mean hawkeye just
runs with the gauntlet and then hands it
off to the evil nebula
good job there buddy and because of your
murder spree is ronin at the beginning
of the movie there is no chance that
clint is passing muster
meanwhile black widow plus a godlike
hammer
add her to that girl power shot my
friends speaking of girl power what
about another strong female from the
series
during an interview with buzzfeed brazil
a few months back brie larson made the
claim that captain marvel was
definitely worthy of mjolnir do you
think captain marvel
is able to lift taurus hammer definitely
are you sure about that one bree
i think you might be getting strength
confused with worth
sure at the end of captain marvel she's
doing her best to roam the cosmos
protecting the helpless but captain
marvel hasn't shown herself to be
self-sacrificing
she arrogantly believes that everyone
including thanos himself
is no match for her because before you
didn't have me if she doesn't see there
being a threat in the first place
then it's not much of a sacrifice for
her to enter the battle
is it and that's actually kind of my
problem with this character so far
there are no stakes in a fight that she
has no concern about winning but
that's not all she also tends to resort
to violence very quickly
clearly she holds a personal grudge
against the cree at the end of captain
marvel
outright challenging ronan the accuser
during the final space
battle her method of punch first ask
questions later isn't going to be
earning her
any quality hammer time so no bree i
have to disagree
speaking of strength and sacrifice we
can quickly eliminate the hulk as well
losing to thanos didn't make hulk humble
in the slightest if anything it made him
more arrogant than ever before
say green granted this isn't really
disqualifying on its own but you know
what is hulk's motto
not really the phrase of someone who's
going to be used in diplomacy first
even when he snaps using the gauntlet
and end game he still thinks that he's
gonna be fine he specifically
says it's like i was made for this
indicating that his best guess is that
he would survive
not much of a sacrifice not much of a
pacifist not so worthy in the eye
of odin which brings us to the grand
finale the third
and final snapper perhaps the most
interesting name to consider on this
list
thanos himself you may remember last
year when i made the outrageous claim
that thanos was right so is it possible
that thanos
is in fact worthy i mean sure he's
treated as the villain of these movies
but
in principle his mission seems solid
even if it is a bit misguided he's going
around
planet to planet wiping out half of all
life to help those who remain
he doesn't want what happened on his
home planet to happen to anyone else's
it is in his mind a noble mission and
based on what we've seen about how the
hammer works
worthiness isn't about being right or
wrong it's about intention
how pure is your desire to help based on
what we see
you can make a strong case for him
meeting our two criteria
first self-sacrifice in pursuit of his
noble mission thanos shows himself
willing to make the hard sacrifices for
what he perceives to be the greater good
he sacrifices his greatest love his
own daughter gamora off the cliff we see
him gravely injured after using the
infinity stones not just once but
twice making him so weak that he's
finished off without trouble at the
beginning of endgame
in a way he is repeatedly making the
ultimate sacrifice of his own life as
well as the lives of those he loves
purely to achieve this goal of helping
other people
in the way that only he knows how to do
one clip alone sums this up best
did it cost everything as for avoiding
violence as a first resort
yeah you could argue that he does this
too in endgame he sits around and waits
until
all the other heroes attack him he
doesn't seek out the violence he lets it
come to him
on an even bigger scale though he just
sits around on his floating space throne
and waits for literally the entire
series
only choosing to step in to fight when
it's clear that no one else is going to
be able to help him accomplish his
mission
but perhaps the biggest point in his
favor is that once he accomplishes his
elimination of half of all life
he stops from what we see on gamora's
home planet and on earth
thanos only pursues violence insofar as
it's necessary for the task that he sets
out to do
could he have killed more people
absolutely but he
doesn't at least he doesn't until they
continue to bring the fight back to him
where did that bring you back to me
it seems like even the movie's editors
knew that this was the case considering
that in promotional materials for
infinity war
thanos says fun isn't something one
considers from balancing the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
which would seem to indicate that he
does get some joy out of this process
but the line was cut from the final
release of the film
for being a warring titan thanos is
shockingly reserved and again
this cannot be overstated enough when he
gets control over all the infinity
stones he has the power of the universe
in his hand he still doesn't use the
stones for his own personal gain
he doesn't use them to kill needlessly
he uses them
once to help everyone and then he uses
them again to destroy them so that no
one can undo his actions
that is it even the choice of him using
the stone to accomplish his mission is a
point in his favor
look at how he describes it with all six
stones i could simply snap my fingers
they would all cease to exist and i call
that
mercy it's a clean way of killing it's
not violent or
painful like he says it is a merciful
way to go
he's clearly thought this through for
the best interests of everyone
all those who live as well as all those
who are gonna die
so is thanos actually worthy of wielding
mjolnir while there's a great case to be
made for thanos there is
one final consideration he's helping
people
who aren't looking for help themselves
sure his
goals may be noble and yes he may only
commit as much violence as he needs to
in pursuit of that mission but he's also
imposing his will on others without
their consent
they didn't ask for help and yet thanos
comes storming into their planet to
outright tell them what to do with
extreme actions of violence
is that the definition of worthy no
no it's not this would be the deal
breaker
at least it would be the deal breaker
for most people but remember
we're not worried about most people
we're worried about
one person in this franchise in
particular odin odin is the one who
casts the charm on mjolnir and this
whole time we've been asking
what is worthy in the eye of odin it's
easy to forget that odin himself like
thanos was a conqueror odin subjugated
the nine realms because he too thought
that it was an act that served a greater
good according to hella and thor
ragnarok he slaughtered
untold amounts of people to achieve this
goal has no one been taught our history
i was his weapon in the conquest that
built asgard's empire
one by one the realms became ours it was
only
after he finished his task that he
decided to become a peaceful king
thanos quest actually falls into the
same territory
be violent and be hated while you're
taking over but retire
and let those who remain be peaceful
after it's all over
as thanos himself says the hardest
choices require the strongest
wills something odin would be inclined
to agree with
so is thanos worthy of mjolnir i would
have to say that in the marvel cinematic
universe
yes he is worthy in most people's
definition of worthy i'd say no but
based on the evidence that we see across
all these movies as well as the morals
of odin the man who made the enchantment
in the first place
thanos is within the bounds of
worthiness he
should be able to lift mjolnir maybe
that's why he's able to stop
stormbreaker in the final endgame scene
maybe that's why it doesn't end in the
way how it should've ended proposed with
thor launching the hammer at him and
just perma pinning him down it actually
opens up a lot of really interesting
avenues but now he's dead without
realizing that he was worthy in the
first place just like natasha
and tony man if only people had stopped
and asked themselves this question
before they got into a climactic final
battle hindsight is 20 20. which is
useful in the marvel cinematic universe
considering you have a time stone that
turns things backwards in time so bring
back thanos and black widow
and tony and let them wield the power of
thor it would be so cool
a three-way battle royale with the
hammer if you make that happen disney
that is the thing that'll get me to
subscribe to your new disney plus
subscription service
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
cuts
[Music]
you